有,有聲音
等一下可以測試一下
看這個錄影有沒有成功錄到聲音
今天有錄影嗎?
沒有
他上到第二場然後下課
然後才來下課
才想到
請大家先登入那個Google Meet
然後Google Meet的連結就在EEKS
上面那個同一個
今天上的那個拍G&T
然後我請老師去找火山跟地震的資料
還有哈斯巴的資料
然後我讓同學用拍G&T去畫出一些板塊邊界的
那個位置的地形圖
對 用Collab去畫
然後接下來就是
把他們畫的那個圖呢
再用3D鏈印出來
給他們可以實際去看
然後之後我有想過一個方式
我們現在都是看那個板塊邊界
然後去分析
或者去描述這個邊界
它的地震活動的特性
或是火山的特性
但我們可能可以有一個活動
就是告訴同學
某一個地方
它的地震可能都是淺的
然後呢
他沒有火山
然後他
他沒有出漏地表
或者有出漏地表
然後他有什麼地形特徵
然後請他猜
這裡可能是
什麼樣的板塊邊界
造成這樣的地質特徵
我們可以
後面會反過來這樣用
所以到此後
我覺得這個課程
還蠻有趣的
然後他們最後一堂課
有用AI去做一個網頁
那那個網頁可以讓他們直接把地圖畫出來
然後是一個互動式的
他就不用每次都要用那個拍GNT
然後自己手畫
然後這個教材
我覺得大家可以參考一下
因為很難得有一個人幫我們整理了
怎麼使用拍GNT
然後可以畫地圖
畫火山
畫地震
畫剖面圖
然後還可以畫3D的
這是一個很好的教材
大家好好看一下它的GitHub裡面的三個教案
從Readme進去有三個
然後三個就是按照順序看
因為它有一個順序
其實是可以自學
如果你把它看完之後
然後看完之後趕快focus它的GitHub
這樣以免以後找不到
那你就可以在你自己的裡面
可以用裡面的資源
然後我們的那個專題題目呢
我覺得可以增加一個
因為最近七項署的顧問
京都大學教授
Matsumi Yamada
他來我們這邊訪問
然後他有講一個題目
叫做Sonic Bomb
就是在日本去年的時候有一個奇怪現象
就是有那個彗星從外面外太空打過來之後呢
然後那個它沒有打到地表
但是它在空中爆炸之後
它的振波傳到地表
然後沿著地表
然後影響到很多地震儀都可以收到訊號
然後它這個Sony Bomb
它可以透過地震儀
然後去定位Sony Bomb的位置
然後可以看出它的一些現象
幾點幾分幾秒在哪裡
然後爆炸
然後我們就受到它這個talk的那個啟發
我們就想到臺灣曾經有一個
有個很巨大的爆炸
我覺得可能是目前為止最大的一個爆炸
是在2014年
你們知道我講哪個
高雄七爆
所以我們就跟他說
說臺灣有一個高雄氣爆
然後
對臺中那個也
哎
臺中那個氣
剛好日本這一次的熊本九州那個地震也有一個氣爆
他也給我們看了那個例子
就是熊本那個地震過了一個小時之後呢
有個百貨公司叫伊勇
日本很有名的伊勇大賣場
然後爆炸跟我們一樣就是百貨公司爆炸
然後他那個爆炸的聲波傳出去之後
它附近的地震儀都有收到
然後地震儀也可以定位
然後也可以看到那個
那個sonic wave
就是升坡的震動
然後也有那個升坡打到地面
然後沿著地面傳遞
所以它其實有兩個訊號
一個是空中的那個升坡
一個是地面來的那個批坡
然後因為它講了這兩個talk之後
我們就想臺灣有高雄氣泡
會不會高雄氣泡也看得到
這個訊號
然後老師超厲害的
他11點半講完這個演講
然後11點40的時候
我們跟他做有這個case
然後他馬上問我們說
那個資料哪裡下載
然後2點我們就去吃飯嘛
吃完飯大概快1點
然後休息到2點
然後1點到2點
直接就把PPT做好了
他就看到那個高雄氣爆
我們也有這樣的訊號
然後我們就想說
說臺灣其實不只高雄氣爆
還有什麼蘆洲爆炸
還有其他的爆炸案
可能也可以透過立正宜去看到這些訊號
然後他說
我們不能一直叫他做
就是接下來我們要自己做
我們不能一直把資料給他
然後他一直做
所以他有告訴我們怎麼做
然後我想說這個很適合當專題
然後就可以給大家來
當成題目來做
然後我回家有想
就是每個人選一個專題
然後來做
這是一個方法
但另外一個方法就是
大家一起做同一個
然後有點像上課這樣
就是譬如說我們現在
大家一起來做高雄氣爆這個題目
然後大家都一起去看資料
然後一起分析
然後看看成果
然後大家一起做那個
那個地震活動分析
然後就看成果
這樣每個禮拜
每個禮拜都會有一個主題
然後就是每個人都可以
參與同一個題目
那當然如果你們想要
最終會有你自己
一個一直follow的題目
那個你就可以看看
我們這幾個禮拜以來
就是這樣
每一個題目都做一遍
然後你可以選一個
你真正有興趣的
然後再往下繼續做比較深入
我覺得這個方式好像不錯
就是我們等於說在meeting的時候
就直接討論那個某一個專題
然後在討論的時候大家先一起做
然後之後在全部都一輪之後呢
大家再個別針對自己的興趣去進行
所以我現在想把那個PVT給大家看一下
我們今天來看兩個專題
然後下禮拜可以來看看大家做的如何
就有一個我有先準備的是那個地震活動那一個
那我現在先來看一下那個阿蘇米的那一個
然後把這個檔案放到EE Class
我都把它放在這個標題裡面好了
這個專題研究
這個要怎麼樣讓它一直置頂
好像可以對不對
移動
可是我在最底
你在最底
還是說把它放在最新公告
然後置頂
然後這個應該可以移到那個裡面
這個移動
然後我在這裡面新增一個檔案
然後大家來看一下這個檔案
這個是在2014年臺北時間
7月31號晚上11點
大概五十六分的時候
有一個主要的爆炸
那它這個爆炸不是一個點緣的爆炸
它不是那種化學工廠
然後一個點的爆炸
它是一個
線圓的爆炸
因為它是沿著底下的
管線
然後
這樣
一路這樣
爆炸下去
而且它可能
可能是一起爆
也可能是
按順序爆
但是
時間應該都很接近
然後這個是
當時的
地震儀紀錄到的訊號
那從
我記得他是說從9點開始
然後這邊是
這是秒
然後
然後他做了一個濾波
他把這個原始的訊號做了2到8赫茲的濾波
然後想要去看那個爆炸訊號
然後對應到的時間大概就是這個地方
這個地方是晚上的11點56左右
然後他有看到一個訊號
這裡有兩個
然後其他不是很明顯
然後這個是原始資料
然後再做2到8赫茲的濾波
它不同的地震儀器
有那個井下地震儀
也有地表地震儀
有寬屏也有加速度
那這些資料都可以從GDMS上面下載
所以每個人都可以載得到這些資料
然後它就做了兩條線
這一條線呢
這個是批播
它有在附近
的地震站有看到明顯的P波
然後這條斜線的斜率剛好是每秒大概300公尺的速度
但是那個就是升波的速度
所以如果說它有
地震有收到那個爆炸的升波的訊號的話
應該會出現在這條線上面
如果是地表傳遞過來的P波
那就是會出現大概就在這條線上
那因為這些站的距離都很近
然後所以P波的這個斜率
看起來就是就一點點
就是它在短時間內可以移動很長的距離
這個Y軸是距離
這一張又更明顯一些
這些P波其實蠻明顯的
然後那個深坡呢
這裡好像看到有一根
有一個
那這兩個可能有
但是跟那個P波
有混在一起
然後後面就不太清楚
然後再放大來看
就是這裡
這個P波其實非常的明顯
然後如果再看一下
說這些站的P波
其實都有看到
那把這個訊號拿去做評估
分析
可以看到主要的
能量相當的高頻
在20赫茲
然後迅速的就
能量衰減
然後變成比較低頻的訊號
0到不知道多少
然後
這邊也可以看到它的能量
從很高頻的20赫茲一直衰減到
0赫茲
然後它的爆炸看起來不是
只有一次性的爆炸
是有很多次的爆炸
累積起來
這個就是他簡單的分析
那我們可以
我們可能可以
現在做一件事情
就是跟他做一樣的事
我們用OBS-TY
然後用AI去幫我們寫程式
然後資料來源就是GDMS
然後把資料下載之後呢
去抓那個時間點
在這個時間點
這是UTC time
那我們抓的資料也是這個UTC time
然後可能往後抓一小時
往前抓30分鐘
可是它這已經有比較提前
那我們可以去上網看
它主要的爆炸時間是23點56分
那UTC time應該是15點56分
所以它從13點開始抓
算是抓得蠻前面的
然後讓你的抓的資料有涵蓋
這整個爆炸的時間點
然後再去把資料做簡單的綠薄
2到8赫茲
然後去畫圖
然後觀察看看能不能看到這個現象
這個就當做我們第一個要做的事情
先把這個爆炸案的訊號
然後看能不能做出來
出來跟老師做的這個長得很像
先做的跟他一樣
表示我們有具備一些分析的能力
然後再去我先去找幾篇paper
是跟這個有關的
然後就可以往下做
再去看看其他的爆炸案的case
然後我們把這所有的爆炸案case收集起來
然後可能可以做一些分析
然後那個
馬蘇米老師說他很想看其他爆炸案的case
我們的資料做得如何
然後這其實是一個機會
如果大家以後想要去日本
搞不好可以去找他
他在京都大學仿債研究所
如果我們做得很好
就是搭上一條線
那你就可以去找他
然後做研究或是什麼的
以後可能會有機會
所以這是一個這個我想應該已經這個講得蠻清楚
那我把這個這個題目把它放進去
好然後再來就是我有先開了三個GitHub
等之後就會把一些資料往上面丟
然後我想要收集你們的keyhub的email
可以這樣弄
可以弄一個組織
這樣怎麼弄
要
創一個組織要再邀請
keyhub有一個選單
然後我就不會了
有什麼聯絡
我開 金針教 中文信訪
很多節目
我都知道
有一個New Organization
那個
喔
不是
沒有 他沒有寫
沒有 有Free的
有Free的
可是他好像
我知道他的
New Organization
好 那我們來建立一個
就分年度好了
因為老師可能會有很多Organization
就今年
今年的
要避免很多人叫U臺北
所以U臺北2026打一張
May only contain
不可以有那個底線
就這個
然後
然後這個是什麼
邀請
邀請別人來
那欸欸你們把那個你的
user name 貼在貼在貼在這個訊息
現在訊息完我直接把它複製貼過來就好
順便在那個masonjue上面請大家
今天沒有來的人提供一下
email可以email可以
Give him the e-mail.
做的功夫,你們 cutting
重 almondsum
哈哈哈哈
火龍
誰是李宗盛?
王
美妙
好像要請大家去那個confirm是不是
給我那個email我來幫忙加
然後在那個Organization 裡面要怎麼用啊
你可以自己
跟他講說緊急爆裂
push 到這個
記得上去不都會有個選項
你要記得哪裡
你可以選擇你可以到這裡
那我現在在這邊的
如果直接按New repository
會進來這裡嗎
還是舊的可以轉進來嗎?
為什麼?
我現在
create一個
repository
但是好像看不出來它在
organization裡面
對啊
關聯性是這樣
在外面
create的時候可以選
有選單可以選
他會把我後面這個人選擇
哦 原來如此
然後也跟我們分殺吧
你之後 反正以後的時間在這裡
你之後看你要捆到你自己的隊伍
所以這個就會變成Private
對 之後就說
應該是我們也不所謂的解釋
那時候就獲得下來的作用
不查一次的話
就我不能增改啊
你要的話就copy一個副本
對不對
不然我剛出去
open my own API
就有點
怪怪的
你會懂就換學生
如果我改進就好
現在講的比較好笑
我就沒有那麼喜歡
換吧
那你只要卡時間去喔
而且你的照片跟我一樣都沒有超白
我不知道他的那個去找
他不知道那個是什麼鬼
對對對
他剛跟我說我去男生的
我喜歡你
你說你傷腹結嗎
不是
不是啊
你得記他啦
他
在唱什麼
他們是對的
他們是紅色衣的唱片
對
他送我們吃飯
要空了
回來了
對
沒時間
太可惜了
對不起
我剛剛坐著
笑了
你有跟他打招呼
我還要問問我的朋友
沒有 你剛剛說
我洗臉
我回答
要聽耶
要聽
不免資訊
要把頭縫起來
然後我們就把這個
好
那我現在把他移過來
對不對
可以用縫
這一個PyGNT是你剛剛Folk的
我看不到Folk的按鈕
就是先去那個地方按Folk
然後它可以讓你選Organization
那我知道怎麼弄
所以像我已經建了三個
我就這個我就直接去Folk就好了
然後這邊再選Organization就好了
瞭解
所以現在我們有三個
你這其實蠻方便的
那就是你那所以就不需要用Public對不對
對,我把它改一下
去哪裡改?Public
不能改Visibility
用Folk的不能改
對
每個人都可以
你只要是
你只要在這個程度
我就說所有程度
你都可以
你可以在這邊
你要看他開的電線
都夠了
好 我就假設
因為我是說假設我要
那你看陳柏駿有開FOC
那這個不能改
只要是公開了就可以
不是 你看在網路上可以FOC很多的
這個沒有 這是全新的
就只要要看全新的
如果開私人的話好像別的就沒有辦法
我們就沒有辦法再FOC
我們就只好開公開
如果要FOC到自己
在酒駕的話就沒有辦法了
他們剛剛這邊沒有辦法再FOC
改成私人的
所以好像公開會比較簡單
但是可以download吧
有一些資料我覺得不要public比較好
因為我們有一個專案是地震預警的分析
我有一天去那邊也不想
上面有個記錄在上面
不一定不能回家
別人可以看你的粉絲
反正就找不到你
好
OK
我們
但是
這就是
因為如果
如果啊,就像我這邊是
如果他就給你PoP了,就好像是一個PoP了
那個PoP的型別
反正就是沒有化石
反正我都會用PoP
因為我就是,我都會用PoP
對
你可以猜
但是我可以點,所以你可以點
但你就是不知道他
你可以想辦法馬虎一下
這都很快
對 都很快
你可以選擇你要不要給別人
你還可以直接使用
就是這個成果
就是每個人可以把電池用掉
對 然後假設如果以後有麻煩的東西
你就自己下來使用
你沒辦法送到我現在手上
你可以自己停下來
自己收聽這些
但是不能收到電池的
應該是吧
因為我也沒有找過
我就是沒有比較會用
是啦
因為其實
因為聽話也沒什麼時間用
也沒什麼用
聽起來就很爛
聽過也還沒知道在講
不是啊
就是你要講它是中文
你要講它是中文
要用自己身體
自己身體
對
而且你會這樣
像是黃俊佳
他想要講一個句子
他就
超瘋啦
你講這麼多句好不好
什麼是屁指?
他可以回到製作
他有個屁指
誰該怎麼做
就該怎麼做
那個
那個前輩
屁指的翻譯是
蠢蛋
這根本不是
好大陸的
這是生物
我覺得那個氣氛
氣氛好像一直在我身上
氣氛小時候
氣氛是
你不知道這個嗎
不知道
太陽
那你第一份吧
你是我的一份
那是因為我看不到嗎
還沒過那麼長時間
他是不是有解釋怎麼做的
那我是不是可以有這個
沒有 你有看同意還是沒有
我們應該會去那邊拿照片
我們應該要跟他們談一談
他快跑來
他明明怎樣 你讓他拍也沒有去
我知道
所以他馬上就自然醒了
然後說我要跳舞了
我回家了
然後就開始睡了
因為你避暑
避暑是不是
避暑
說得對嘛
你避暑
你不能不寫他就可以這樣
因為我腦
充得大
因為我幾點
偷偷偷偷
因為我腦充不得
好不像我們
大家都不慌
你們要上課
你們看我慌嗎
衣服都沒穿
好
那我們現在有七個專案
然後我會慢慢把東西放進去
那我們先
我們先來看第七個
然後請大家一起來做這個
下個禮拜的討論的題目就是這個期
然後請大家模仿一下
仿造一下他的這個內容
把這些圖自己畫出來
自己找資料
然後自己畫出來
這個就是下禮拜要討論的
我也會做
然後大家一起做
這樣就可以有東西討論
看看大家做的情況怎麼樣
好然後這個做完之後下一個再去做另外一個
可能是那個SysMetrics的Forecasting
然後一個一個做下去
然後進加你的那個CodeDiff
你那CodeDiff我們就另外討論
可是我最近想要
你還要那個
我這個可以先站好嗎
可以你先弄你的
我們還要測試用不一樣的
就是直接做
取消那個GMP的部分
好
那我們今天討論到這
好謝謝